Mm, I love a glass of pinot noir during work.
Mmm...notes of blackberry, chocolate, and
Ooo.
What’s this?
Ah, yes, a no-so-subtle bouquet of stink bugs.
Hello winos, it’s Natalia for DNews!
When it comes to producing wine, vineyards
have many elements to contend with like rainfall,
soil conditions, and... stink bugs that hitch
rides into the wineries.
Yes, brown marmorated stink bugs enjoy feeding
on grapes and end up becoming “one with
the wine” as they are hard to find and remove
because they’re a similar color to the grapes.
And when stressed during the pressing process,
the stink bugs, true to their name, emit an
unpleasant smelling compound, (E)-2-decenal.
It is said to smell like cilantro or coriander.
Researchers from Oregon State University have
now determined that there can be up to three
stink bugs per bunch of grapes before the
levels of (E)-2-decenal negatively affect
a tasty bottle of wine.
You think that’d keep me from drinking wine,
but it won’t.
Almost no commercially produced food is going
to be completely devoid of ‘filth’.
The FDA says, quote, “it is economically
impractical to grow, harvest, or process raw
products that are totally free of non-hazardous,
naturally occurring, unavoidable defects.”
So what other undesirable critters are in
your food?
I hope you’re not eating.
The “Filth” in our food includes insect
fragments, grubs, rodent hairs, and rodent
excrement.
For example… aphids love to get into your
garden, so it should come as no surprise they
are in your produce.
The FDA estimates that there are about 60
aphids per 100 grams of frozen broccoli, and
30 aphids per 100 grams of brussel sprouts.
And that jar of peanut butter in your cupboard
has, on average, 30 insects fragments and
1 rodent hair per 100 grams.
The FDA states there is an average of 9 mg
of rodent excrement pellets and pellet fragments
in one kilogram of wheat.
Anyone want a sandwich?
To make sure food remains safe for public
consumption, the FDA has regulations in place
to ensure commercially produced food isn’t
brimming with these undesirables.
But even treated water can have a certain
degree of fecal matter in it.
I mean it’s a very minute amount, but I
still call it poo water.
You ok there, buddy?
All this talk of insects in our food begs
the question, is eating insects so bad?
Maybe it’s ok to eat a little bug or three.
Heck, maybe it’s even good for us!
According to anthropologist Julie Lesnik,
entomophagy, or eating insects, is not only
an excellent source of protein, it’s also
something our human ancestors did.
Researchers hypothesize that eating insects
contributed to brain growth, or encephalization,
in primates, including our hominin ancestors.
In terms of nutritional value, dried crickets
are roughly 60% protein and have more calcium
than milk!
Because of these stats, cricket flour has
become all the rage recently, with cricket
protein bars and baked goods being sold throughout
the US.
In fact, it seems the US is behind the times
because people throughout the world have been
eating insects for centuries, from crickets,
to mealworms, to locusts, to flies.
In 2013, the UN urged people to eat insects
in hopes to curb worldwide hunger stating
that at least 2 billion people were already
using insects as a dietary supplement.
Perhaps we ought to reconsider the idea that
eating insects is unclean or gross.
So next time you’re at a restaurant let
your waiter know you’d like that extra fly
in your soup.
Love insects?
Wanna know how they go number 2?
Check out this video!
And what about you?
Would you or do you eat insects?
Let us know in the comments below, subscribe,
and keep coming back here for DNews every
day of the week!